Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Je vous préviens,
aujourd'hui on va se faire peur.
Je vais vous parler
d'une créature qui a semé la terreur
au XVIIIᵉ siècle en France.
Tellement, qu'on en parle
encore aujourd'hui.
La bête du Gévaudan.
En moins de trois ans, elle a provoqué
la mort d'une centaine de personnes.
S'agissait-il réellement d'un animal ?
À quoi ressemblait-t-il et a-t-on réussi à le capturer ?
Il y a un peu de vrai et un peu de faux
dans tout ce qu'on entend.
On fait le tri dans cette histoire.
Si ce format vous plait, n'hésitez
pas à liker cette vidéo.
J'ai plein d'histoires
comme celle-ci dans mes tiroirs.
Le 30 juin 1764,
une jeune bergère âgée de quatorze
ans, Jeanne Boulet,
est retrouvée morte près de Langogne,
un petit village du Gévaudan.
Le Gévaudan
est une ancienne province
royale du sud de la France.
Elle s'étendait sur l'actuel
département de la Lozère
et une partie de la Haute-Loire.
À l'époque,
c'est une terre d'élevage très pauvre
et beaucoup moins boisée qu'aujourd'hui.
C'est un paysage couvert de landes et de
prairies, avec quelques forêts au milieu.
C'est bon.
J'ai déjà peur.
C'est justement à la lisière
d'un petit bois
que le corps mutilé de la bergère
est découvert.
Il est entaillé de griffures.
On constate aussi de profondes morsures.
À première vue, ce crime ne peut pas
être imputé à un homme.
Le curé de la paroisse
mentionne d'ailleurs dans son registre
que la fillette a été dévorée,
je cite, par la bête féroce.
Alors s'agit-il d'un effet de style
exprimant la violence du crime
ou doit-on en conclure
que la bergère a été victime d'un animal ?
Jeanne Boulet n'est
pas la première à avoir croisé son chemin.
Depuis 1763, on a déjà recensé une dizaine d'attaques étranges dans la région.
Il pourrait donc s'agir du même suspect.
Par chance, les victimes précédant
Jeanne Boulet ont eu la vie sauve.
On possède donc plusieurs témoignages
assez précis qui permettent
de décrire ce suspect.
Et à priori, il s'agit bien d'un animal.
Selon une paysanne qui lui a échappé de justesse,
la bête ressemblerait à un loup,
mais un loup XXL et qui aurait la taille
d'un veau.
Elle précise que l'animal est roux
et qu'il porte une rayure noire
le long du dos.
Sa tête est énorme et allongée, sa gueule
remplie de crocs pointus et démesurés.
Quant à ses yeux, ils sont rouges.
Cette description terrifiante
ne correspond à aucun animal.
Le 8 août 1764,
Une seconde victime est retrouvée morte.
Encore une gardienne de troupeaux.
Son corps est en lambeaux.
La pauvre fille est défigurée.
Ce sont ses vêtements
qui permettent de l'identifier.
Mais c'est horrible.
Ça fait deux agressions mortelles
en un peu plus d'un mois dans la région.
Dans la région,
la peur commence à s'installer.
Les bergers,
plus menacés que les autres, forment
des groupes pour ne plus être isolés.
On fait aussi appel à l'armée
pour tenter de débusquer l'animal.
En février 1765, entre 20 et 30000
habitants, hommes et femmes,
sont mobilisés.
On organise plusieurs battues,
mais en vain.
La bête échappe aux poursuites.
Malgré la traque,
les attaques reprennent de plus belle.
Les cibles sont toujours les mêmes
de jeunes gardiens ou gardiennes
de troupeaux et des enfants isolés.
On les retrouve égorgés,
parfois décapités.
L'affaire
n'échappe pas aux journaux de l'époque.
Deux publications, Le Courrier d'Avignon
puis la Gazette de France
s'en saisissent, relatant les découvertes macabres
et informant les lecteurs sur l'évolution de l'enquête.
Peut-être parce qu'ils avaient rien
d'autre à se mettre sous la dent ?
En quelques jours, l'information
se répand sur tout le territoire.
On s'arrache les numéros consacrés
à ce fait divers
et à cet animal mystérieux
que l'on surnomme désormais
la bête du Gévaudan.
En à peine un an, des centaines d'articles
sont publiés dans les gazettes,
et pas qu'en France.
La renommée de la bête dépasse
les frontières du royaume de France
pour atteindre l'Angleterre, l'Espagne
et les États allemands.
On en parle jusqu'à
San Francisco en Amérique.
C'est le premier fait divers de l'histoire
de dimension internationale.
Face à la colère du peuple qui monte
un peu partout, attisée par les journaux
qui utilisent ce prétexte
pour remettre en question le pouvoir,
Louis XV doit changer son fusil d'épaule.
Et à bien y réfléchir,
cette affaire pourrait lui être utile.
À cette époque, les finances du royaume
sont dans le rouge.
Le pays a perdu beaucoup d'argent
avec la guerre de 7 Ans
qui l'opposait à l'Autriche
et la Grande-Bretagne.
Pour renflouer les caisses,
il s'apprête à lever un nouvel impôt.
Mais comment faire passer la pilule ?
L'affaire du Gévaudan tombe à pic.
Il offre 10000livres à celui ou celle
qui ramènera la bête à Versailles.
Une largesse qui devrait faire oublier
le nouveau prélèvement.
L'annonce se répand très vite
et des chasseurs venus de toute l'Europe
se ruent sur le Gévaudan.
La traque reprend,
mais la bête reste insaisissable.
Le roi ne se décourage pas.
Il envoie alors ses propres chasseurs
dans le Gévaudan.
Mais là encore, il rentre bredouille.
Finalement, fin septembre 1765,
il missionne son propre arquebusier,
François Antoine, une fine lame.
Et alors ?
Et bien,
bonne pioche !
Le 20 septembre,
il fait un retour triomphal à Versailles
avec un joli trophée.
La dépouille
d'un grand loup que ses hommes ont abattu.
Son allure et ses couleurs correspondent
à la description fournie par les témoins.
On l'empaille et on l'expose
fièrement dans les jardins du roi.
Louis XV a gagné son pari.
Ouf !
Il faut le dire
vite, car quelques semaines plus tard,
les attaques reprennent,
faisant de nouvelles victimes.
Les habitants de la région désespèrent.
Ni les prières,
ni les armes ne mettent fin au cauchemar.
Et puis
le 19 juin 1767,
trois ans après la première attaque,
Jean Chastel,
un chasseur de la région,
surprend un étrange animal.
Son cœur bat la chamade.
Il ajuste son fusil,
aligne la bête et vise.
Il tremble un peu, retient son souffle
pour trouver un peu de calme,
car il ne faut pas louper la cible.
Enfin, il presse la détente et abat
un énorme animal au lieu dit,
la Sogne d'Auvers.
Le spécimen est décrit comme une créature
proche du loup avec une tête hideuse.
La bête est ensuite
conduite à Versailles, où elle est
examinée par le célèbre zoologiste Buffon.
On a cherché, mais malheureusement
il n'a laissé aucun document à ce sujet.
L'animal aurait ensuite été enterré
dans le parc de Versailles
où, dit-on, ses ossements se trouveraient
encore aujourd'hui.
Toujours est-il qu'à partir de ce moment,
les attaques ont cessé.
Clap de fin ?
Et bien non !
Au contraire même, la légende de
la bête du Gévaudan ne fait que commencer.
Pour de nombreux spécialistes de l'affaire,
l'animal abattu par Jean
Chastel n'était pas le bon.
La publicité faite autour de sa capture
n'aurait servi qu'à éteindre l'incendie.
De nouvelles hypothèses, plus folles
les unes que les autres, commencent alors
à courir sur la véritable identité du monstre.
On pense par exemple,
que cet étrange animal
aurait servi à masquer la présence
d'un tueur en série dans la région.
Celui-ci aurait agi accompagné
d'un gros chien,
mais aucun indice ne le prouve.
D'autres avancent la possibilité
d'un fauve égaré,
une hyène ou un jeune lion.
Dans cette région à cette
époque, c'est quand même peu probable,
à moins qu'il s'agisse
d'un animal retenu en captivité
par un aristocrate du coin,
qui se serait échappé.
Plusieurs historiens contemporains
ont également tenté de faire la lumière
sur cette étrange affaire.
Dans un livre,
intitulé Monsters of the Gévaudan,
l'Américain Jay M Smith,
spécialiste de l'histoire de France,
émet une idée nouvelle.
Les agressions n'auraient pas été le fait d'un seul animal,
mais d'une meute de loups.
L'écrivain Bernard Soulier,
qui, lui, est originaire du village
où la bête a été abattue,
penche pour une autre hypothèse,
celle d'un animal hybride
quelque chose entre un chien et un loup.
Dans un livre publié en 2010,
le journaliste Jean-Claude Bourret valide
quant à lui l'hypothèse que l'animal
tué en juin 1767, serait bien la bête
du Gévaudan.
En 2016, il en propose même une reconstitution sur la base
des descriptions faites à l'époque.
Une gueule monstrueuse
avec des yeux rouges.
Bah, ça me donne pas envie d'aller lui
caresser l'échine à cette bestiole.
Aura-t-on
un jour le fin mot de l'histoire ?
En attendant, la bête du Gévaudan
continue de fasciner les foules.
À Langogne,
où la bête a fait sa première victime,
une sculpture de 1 mètre 20 de haut
sur 2 mètres de long
se dresse à l'entrée de la commune.
Le cinéma s'en est aussi emparé
au début des années 2000.
Le film "Le Pacte des Loups",
réalisé par Christophe Gans, s'est
inspiré de l'histoire de la bête.
Il attire à l'époque
plus de 5 millions de spectateurs.
Un carton !
Si vous désirez
en apprendre plus sur ce fait divers,
il existe une association nommée "Au pays
de la Bête du Gévaudan",
dont l'objectif est de défendre et de faire connaître
la vérité historique à son sujet.
Enfin, pour celles et ceux qui aiment
se faire peur
à Saugues, en Haute-Loire,
un musée retrace
les aventures de cet animal mystérieux.
Si vous n'avez pas assez frissonné
cet hiver, il y a de quoi vous rattraper.
Voilà, c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout.
J'espère ne pas vous avoir trop effrayé,
ni dissuadé d'aller visiter
ces beaux départements
que sont la Lozère et la Haute-Loire.
Promis, juré
aucun monstre
n'y a été signalé depuis plus de 200 ans.
À très bientôt.